hey reject nation Greg he'll be here
John we're gonna watch video called
introducing Ori Ida potato day patron
video requests that's why we're watching
this one whatever video you requested
was definitely do put up on YouTube is
one of Arbor War tears today comes from
Gregory Oleg Gregory Bullock is a
handsome man of african-american descent
my brother yoke hi Greg did you hear him
on pledge sorry I'm just trying to it's
a nice room it's a nice room anyway it's
theoretical room for a to do a google
hangout with him in a little bit good
thing he's not seeing this video before
we do that hangout but Gregor you have a
lot of messages on patreon you and I a
lot of back and forth and I love talking
with you man
I know sometimes life can be a little
bit challenging but keep your head up
high because you are one optimistic soul
that really infuses my heart with a lot
of positivity so thank you for being you
don't ever change unless it means
growing in a positive direction don't
even change your clothes don't even
change your underwear no probably an
experiment we're gonna watch this
without audio first let's see if it
changes when we put the audio man just
have one broccoli yeah
disgusting parents is this struggle
familiar and yeah who has time for this
and don't expect the foggers to have the
answer the solution is here bribery
that's right innocence with a little
over the table bribery is it ethical
[Music]
even the friends they love to eat they
don't do you not have a problem with
this we're just going to trust them and
then one morning she does make some
really good point but I know what you're
thinking maybe I'm not comfortable with
bribery I'm not comfortable with
well-needed potato pay it's the same
bribery we all know and love only now
[Music]
visit try potato pay calm for tools and
tips on how to start bribing or Cho half
a day o or Ida Oregon on Idaho I had no
idea wow this is real this is a real
commercial it would appear it's on the
or Ida potatoes official YouTube
channels so this is going about
convincing your kid to bribe them with
french fries to eat their healthy food
yeah yeah give them bad food to eat
their healthy food uh-huh no a shocking
commercial I mean I wasn't like you know
vulgar or sexual but like this is really
a weird way to promote your fries well I
don't know I mean I've kind of gotten
used to this tambour of advertising in
the past few years because people have
figured out that if you make your
advertising kind of cheeky and
self-aware and meta like that works um
but like the Old Spice commercials with
Isaiah Mustafa have like reinvented the
way we do all this now where it's like
I'm a random woman and I'm gonna be
self-aware and talk at you so I thought
this was really funny but I'm not I
guess surprised that they did it
yourself into a meme it's a weird way to
occur like knowing what your product is
and honing in on that for laughs
weirdly makes me go I'd buy these fries
they've got a good sense of humor
there's not trouble they're not trying
to manipulate me into thinking this is
something it's not yeah yeah yeah you're
literally just being like hey you want a
more fun version of a vegetable to go
with your boring version of a veget and
hey I don't know what's in their fries
maybe they are on the healthier side of
the French fry spectrum I didn't see
that coming that delivery of the one
woman who comes in yes in about bribery
who has time for this kind of a positive
reinforcement maneuver I guess eat your
broccoli fun stuff will happen that's
how I treat my diet that's how I treat
my daughter for every with the fries I
give her the fries Jean the Douglas
broccoli okay there are times we live in
now where you got to be careful what you
say I'm sorry
jokes are the Bible context does not
matter anymore we should go to try
potato Paycom I've always wanted to have
fries shipped to me I've got that lady
did great delivery a lot of times you
watch commercial actors you're like
these are commercial these actors are
like you guys seem like you could do
like real sketches actually yeah guys
how do you feel about bribing your
children do you think this is ethical or
you outraged let us know in the comments
below subscribe to the reject nation I
think you should bribery kids click that
notification bell because subscribe
buttons are broken and hey chicks on
page tram I got full-length TV show
reactions wetly queueing this music
video coverage would love to have you
become a patreon objected
[Music]